>> Yes we would like the World Cup event in
South Africa to benefit the rest of the continent
and we want to do so and we want to do so
by making it possible for Africans to be able
to view the full matches through big-screens
and the signals are conveyed by telecommunications
to villages and cities across the continent.
Secondly, there will be millions of people
traveling to South Africa during that time.
We would like to convince them to also take
a look at some of the tourist attractions
that exist in all of the countries over the
continent. To visit other countries on their
way here, or on the way back. And we are doing
this through a project which we developed
in the NEPAD e-Africa Commission to promote
the event and indicate various countries,
how they might be able to benefit in the two
ways that I have mentioned.